right now facts and science and truth it
is the difference between life and death
Anderson Cooper may have welcomed his
first child into the world last week but
he has no plans of taking time off this
is as serious as it gets the CNN anchor
appeared on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert this week and explained why he
won't be taking a paternity leave
amid the corona virus pandemic
personally it's not this is not some
story I mean this is this is life and
death this is this is as serious as it
gets and it's more important than ever
before that thing's be true and accurate
and and you know it's why I'm not one of
the reasons I you know I'm not taking
time off the 52 year olds announced the
news that he became a dad to a baby boy
last week on his show Anderson Cooper
360 this is Wyatt Cooper he is three
days old and Anderson says the show must
go on
thankfully I can do some work from home
and stuff but I I feel like this is an
extraordinary time to be in this
business as a reporter and to be able to
try to help inform people and give
people fact the TV journalists said he's
had help with his itty-bitty he shared
that his ex Benjamin Massoni is serving
as a co-parent to Wyatt my former
partner Benjamin is going to be a
co-parent two to two Wyatt even though
we're not together anymore but you know
he's my family and I wanted to be quiet
family as well and Anderson's longtime
pal Andy Cohen recently revealed that
his son Benjamin's nanny is also helping
out with Wyatt
we had long planned this transition she
is now with Anderson and I know she's
gonna get Wyatt on a great sleep
schedule just like she got Ben and I'm
so happy for Anderson and get this the
BFFs are sharing more than just a nanny
he's actually really helped me because
my son is entirely wearing hand-me-downs
from
becoming Sun okay a I'm inherently cheap
I wanted my son to be like a
depression-era child who like grows up
wearing hand-me-down clothes
something tells me Benjamin and Wyatt
are going to be besties just like their
dads back in 2016 and he opened up to ET
about his pal AC and shared this
unexpected fun fact I think that what
what might surprise you about Anderson
is how silly he is or can be and how
easily bored he is he and I text each
other often me from the Bravo Clubhouse
he from CNN headquarters and we say I am
so bored our bar for entertainment is
very high
[Music]